améliorer l'accessibilité de la zone
d'activité de Vélizy-Villacoublay après
15 ans de travail le chantier phare du
département des Yvelines voit le jour
cet été avec un nouveau diffuseur entre
la rd57 et la 86 c'est un chantier qui
va durer deux ans
qui va coûter près de 5 millions d'euros
dont la l'originalité la caractéristique
c'est qu'il est cofinancé public privé
avec une légère majorité de part pour le
privé et donc cette c'est un chantier
assez exemplaire c'est un chantier qui
va être techniquement assez exigeant
parce qu'il va falloir qu'on passe sous
cette autoroute sans l'interrompre 80
autres chantiers sont prévus tout au
long de ses congés d'été des travaux
d'entretien et de modernisation autre
chantier emblématique du côté de
Saint-Cyr-l'École avec le réaménagement
de la chaussée des trottoirs et
stationnement et la création de pistes
cyclables sur la RD7 sur la ville des
fermetures nocturnes sont prévues la
commune de Voisins-le-Bretonneux est
aussi concernée sur la RD 91 et la RD36
aménagement de Carrefour pour veiller à
la fluidité de cet axe là c'est un sujet
assez sensible on y était encore la
semaine dernière parce que c'est l'une
des futures voies d'accès à la gare de
la ligne 18 et donc on s'est engagé
auprès des élus locaux et notamment de
ma collègue la mère de voisin le
chantier Dupont de la deuxième dB sur la
rd308 entre Sartrouville et
Maisons-Laffitte débutez l'an passé les
travaux courent jusqu'à l'été 2024 coût
total des 80 un chantier de l'été près
de 24 millions d'euros